the cincinnati bengals uh good news they
found their quarterback bad news he had
his acl badly injured in a just a tough
to watch hit that he took during the
season so we don't know that he's going
to be ready to go for week one but um at
least we know assuming that he fully
recovers whenever he's healthy they've
got the quarterback position taken care
of for years to come the challenge now
becomes
putting players around him in a division
sharing where there are good
quarterbacks there are good teams and
you can be much better as an
organization and still be in last place
in the afc north
yeah no question about it but you know
joe burrow it's going to take him some
time to come back from that mic but when
he does i think this is a team that's
building i mean they've shown a
commitment and free aim to see to go out
and get free agents they did that last
year something they hadn't done in the
past and and so i think this is a team
that's that's building towards something
special it's still going to take him a
few more years especially with borough
depending on how long it takes him to
come back we know he's not going to be
there for the off-season program
probably not for training camp they hope
for week one but we'll see how that
plays out but this is a team to to me
mike that looks like it's building
towards something special and has a core
group of players there
uh that can help them build to that but
they are moving on from a bunch of
veterans to get them younger in age and
we and we've seen that and we're going
to see that this year
and they have to make good decisions
with their draft picks they have to make
good decisions in free agency and they
have to take advantage of the the
potential for joe burrow to attract
players to cincinnati who have options i
don't think this year that happens i
think if i'm one of these guys who is
looking around in free agency and the
salary cap has gotten me cut or it's
kept me from getting the kind of
contract i'd like to get i don't know
enough about joe burrows health in 2021
in march or april or even may to say
i'll go ahead and do a one-year deal for
less than i really want in the hopes of
being part of something special in
cincinnati it's more of a gradual build
for them and i really do think that zach
taylor the coach of that team entering
his third season is going to have to do
something to avoid
being gone after only three years there
were some strong rumors that he was
going to be out after his second season
so strong that the bengals had to issue
a public statement the day after the
season ended to say they're not firing
zach taylor so uh they don't like to pay
people to not work and i don't know what
the guarantee structure in zach taylor's
contract is but once he's at the point
where there's no further guaranteed
money that's when he's at his most
vulnerable of being fired if the team
isn't showing progress and moving toward
being relevant in a tough conference in
a tough division
um joe mixon you know we were talking
earlier today about running backs
and how dangerous it is to pay a running
back well derek henry dalvin cook alvin
kamara all got big contracts and played
well christian mccaffrey had a couple of
fluke injuries that kept him off the
field joe mixon wasn't great and then
had that that was it a foot that just it
yeah it just never really allowed him to
come back and it created a sense that
that they didn't get the return that
they expected on the contract they gave
to him he's got something to prove in
2021 they need him healthy they need
boro healthy and the offense needs to go
through them shireen
yeah absolutely mike and this is a team
that really was statistically not good
in offense or defense and they do have
some young players they can build around
but they've got to be better on both
sides of the ball they have a lot of
work to do going forward mike they do
have cap space they do have another high
draft pick which it seems like they
always have high draft picks but they've
got to use those draft picks well and
draft some players who can come in and
start for them and be more building
blocks to what they have going right now
all right let's do the game that we've
been doing as we take a look at these
teams one at a time one player in each
one player out each who is your guy that
you think will be on the bengals who
isn't currently on the roster
well you know i talked about the cash
base they got 45.8 million projected
under the cap that's 180 million i think
they go out in free agency and i think
they're active in free agency again like
they were last year and joe tooney just
makes too much sense i mean joe burl got
killed last year they gave up too many
sacks he had the the knee injury they've
got to get better protection this isn't
the only move they make mike i don't
think in the offensive line but i think
it's a good start for them to sign uh
the patriots long time left guard i just
it's perfect fit for him he grew up near
cincinnati and if they can offer him a
lot of money it's it's just a good fit
for him to come be a veteran presence in
that offensive line mike
we do see the bengals spend big from
time to time on strangers to the
organization but overall the team has a
long-standing reputation for being
extremely careful with money and they
may be looking for some bargains in free
agency just because they have that cap
space doesn't mean they have to spend it
all like no other team the bengals
identify success as money in versus
money out and they know how to turn a
profit and they're very happy when they
do they don't care about championships
they care about making money and like
every other team at least they don't
they don't build the facade as as
thickly and convincingly as other teams
do so with that said you know there's a
guy out there at receiver where they're
going to need some help who may be a
bargain because of a of us still
lingering ped suspension will fuller is
going to be on the market and the
bengals may be able to get him at a good
price because i don't know that teams
are going to be flocking to will fuller
because of the suspension and because of
the reality that ever he was using
allegedly or actually and he got caught
so he was using something if you don't
use that anymore maybe you're back to
the guy who can't stay healthy but i
could see will fuller being a guy they
make a run at and also just generally
anyone from the rams that zach taylor
has experience with as these guys become
free agents malcolm brown adds some
depth to the backfield um the receiver
josh reynolds becoming a free agent this
year yeah a guy that they could bring
and add to the depth chart so those are
just a few names i know i'm only
supposed to do one but yeah i'll throw
in a couple others give me one or more
than one if you choose on who's going to
be out in cincinnati
well you talked about the receiver
position mike and the help they needed
they ranked 27th in passing and joe
burrow needs more weapons as he needs
more offensive linemen and the problem
was aj green played under the franchise
tag and was not good he was terrible in
fact and you know he's been there 10
seasons he's 32 years old didn't play up
to expectations it's been a long time
since he's had a great great year he did
play all 16 games this year but it was
his worst year statistically 47 catches
523 yards two touchdowns he's moving on
the question will be if he gets a shot
somewhere else i think somebody gives
him a shot if he's willing to take the
minimum and play for the minimum but i
don't see this guy having a big free
agent market based on what's happened to
him over the last couple of years missed
all of 2019 seasons so i think aj aj
green is definitely gone from the
bengals they have no uh sense that
they're going to resign him at all even
if he would take the minimum to stay
there
never should have tagged him it's one
that we could have said a year ago
they're going to regret it if they do it
and they did regret it they paid a lot
of money for a guy who wasn't a factor
he was targeted so many times he caught
like 45 percent of the balls thrown his
way it just didn't work and i agree with
you he'll be gone another guy i think uh
gino atkins if they move on from him
that's 9.6 million that they dump and
again just because they have cap space
doesn't mean they're going to burn at
all they they like to have that cab
space they like to keep that money in
their pockets if they can you know
there's only so much you have to spend
under the salary cap and it's a four
year rolling average and every dollar
that you don't spend that is year marked
for the cap is raw
unadulterated profit and the bengals
understand that like no one else
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports